President Xi Jinping's last Hong Kong
visit was two years ago to mark 20 years
since the handover what was a British
colony to China he minced no words then
about who was in control any attempt ng
China's sovereignty and security
challenge the power of central
government and basic law of Hong Kong or
to use Hong Kong to condemn infiltration
and sabotage against the mainland is an
act that cross the red line but the past
eleven weeks of mass protests in Hong
Kong seemed to cross that red line the
government even calling some of it near
terrorism however there's been not a
single word from sheathe himself unlike
his US counterpart President Donald
Trump who personally involves himself on
topics big and small including these
protests in Hong Kong president she
rarely engages on specific issues
focusing more on the big picture but
some say don't confuse the lack of
FaceTime as lack of direct involvement
on Hong Kong I think anything that China
will do involving Hong Kong will be a
decision directly up to President Xi
Jinping and the top leadership very
closely at his disposal he has lots of
things to take care of and Hong Kong
probably is just one of them one tactic
that top Chinese leadership has decided
on misinformation Twitter and Facebook
have taken steps to block hundreds of
accounts with ties to the Chinese
government Twitter said the accounts
were an orchestrated attempt to
undermine the legitimacy and political
positions of the protest movement and
through lower-level officials the
government has accused Western nations
of meddling a strong visual warning from
Beijing coming several times over the
last two weeks propaganda video of armed
police amassing and training in Shenzhen
just across the border from Hong Kong a
not-so-subtle reminder of mainland might
the stakes are high for the central
government if they can't handle the Hong
Kong situation properly it means a fire
for its one country two systems' it will
affect their real greatly
wants to unify Taiwan with the same one
country two systems'
but if it fails in Hong Kong he won't
work with Taiwan is a threat for the
future all this just six weeks before
the big celebration marking 70 years
since the founding of the People's
Republic of China there'll be a big
military parade here in Beijing and a
showcase speech by XI looking into the
future but a simmering situation Hong
Kong could cast a shadow over that
future Scott hilar al-jazeera Beijing